in your own time usually uh
the the stuff that's your best idea or
work is going to be attacked the most
ferociously probably because it's new or
because they had never seen an opening
of a movie like that or
so so so you have to really be
courageous about
your instincts and your ideas because
otherwise you'll just
you know knuckle under and change it and
then things that might have been
memorable
will be lost so here you are on one hand
is trying to aspire to really do
something on the other hand you're not
allowed to be pretentious
why do you say [ __ ] it my point is is
that what i've learned is that the stuff
that i got in trouble for the casting
for the godfather or the
flag scene and pen was the stuff that
was remembered and what's considered
really the good work and i think it's
fine for young people to out now just
rip off
the people who come before them because
you do that but you always make it your
own
someone today said you ought to love
what you're doing because
you know especially in a movie you
really have to love the project and love
the story because you will
over the time you really will start to
hate it and
and the fact that you say hey but i
really like what this is about
is a very valuable asset
[Music]
i wrote the script of patent and the
script was very controversial when i
wrote it because they thought it was so
so stylized i mean it was supposed to be
like a sort of you know the longest day
and my script of patton you know was
interested
was sort of interested in reincarnation
i had this
very bizarre opening where he stands up
in front of american flag gives a speech
and
ultimately i was i wasn't fired uh
but i was fired meaning that when the
script was done i said okay thank you
very much and i went and hired another
writer and
and that script was forgotten and and i
remember very vividly this long
kind of being raked over the coals for
this opening scene
my point is is that what i've learned is
that the stuff that i got in trouble for
the casting for the godfather or the
flag scene and patent
was the stuff that was remembered and
what's considered
really the good work in your own time
usually
the the stuff that's your best idea or
work is going to be attacked the most
ferociously probably because it's new or
because they had never seen an opening
of a movie like that or
seen a gangster movie done in the style
so so so you have to really be
courageous about
your instincts and your ideas because
otherwise you'll just
you know knuckle under and change it and
then things that might have been
memorable
will be lost when i realized that i was
actually going to make a movie out of
the novel the godfather
i i sat down and began to read the book
very very
carefully and i think it's important to
put your impressions down
on the first reading because those are
the
the initial instincts about what you
thought was good or what you didn't
understand or what you thought was bad
and so i took the book and i actually
wrote my comments right on the on the
book itself
and having gotten through the book with
these few notes and
comments i then made a prompt book out
of it
and i called it the godfather notebook
and put a big warning if found
return to this address for reward
because i recognized that it would have
every opinion that i had on the book
and um interestingly i decided to
break down each section with these
key criteria one was synopsis to
synopsize that particular part of the
book
a paragraph or two saying what up to
there really had happened in terms of
the story
number two was the times which is to say
how did what happen in the story at that
point how do the times
bear on it in this case it was the 40s
so
after world war ii america had a certain
style imagery and tone
this is of course images that seem to
stand out from reading it or even the
tone of the story
number four it says the core and this is
something i think i
borrowed from elia kazan in his notes
from
the way he broke down the play street
car named desire it's published
in uh in a book on directing but for
five i put pitfalls which was to say
how can i screw this up what are dangers
um things that you want to avoid or
or dangers that you're very easily uh
could find yourself in cliches italians
who would talk a like of this
failure to make a convincing setting
losing a basic humanity to all these
people
failing to set up a tension between
godfather and michael
too much exposition here that you don't
know what you're doing or the
camera operator or the cameraman
everybody i mean when you go on a set i
mean
that's one of the reasons george lucas
never directed again no one knows this
but when he
made star wars over there in england
george is sort of a little skinny
version of me
you know and he's not doesn't have the
most physical
kind of stamina and he was so ridiculed
and sort of
you know that kind of jock-like attitude
that cruz can have putting him down for
what he was doing and stuff
he was so unhappy making star wars that
he just thought he'd never do it again i
mean plus he was like
diabetic so he was a little sick and uh
you know so so you know that you really
have to
you have to that's why someone today
said you ought to love
what you're doing because you know
especially in a movie you really have to
love the project and love the story
because you will
over the time you really will start to
hate it and and
and the fact that you say hey but i
really like what this is about
is a very valuable asset i don't look
the same
at the conversation which is something
of me
albeit being inspired by a film like
blow up i mean i saw that film say god i
want to make films like that
and i think it's fine for young people
to out now just rip off
the people who come before them because
you do that but you always make it your
own
and i've seen movies that i could see
are like somewhat
inspired by movies i made the fella who
saw a movie called the yards oh yeah i
didn't see it
i quite liked the film myself you know
and i like
very much the filmmaker and then it
occurred to me i said you know remind
certain things do remind me of my alpha
majes i'm so proud
i remember in one of my books i came
upon i totally
i have to find it uh essay by balzac
that i just have these collections of
these writers i just happen to be
i don't even know how i saw it or had it
but
basically what ballsack said is he said
you know he says
as for young writers taking what we're
doing
and copying it and kind of letting that
be a starting point
we we ask you to do that that we're
proud
to be part of that link and we did it to
those who came before us and
our work is here for all of you young
writers please steal from it
because you can't steal from it because
as you work it will become your own and
then
someone will come and steal from that
and in that way we're alive forever
and that's exactly how i feel about uh
you know a lot of times i see some stuff
that i've done i see it in a
another film or more likely a music
video and i said gee i'm proud
that they that that was useful to them
and i hope
then someone gets it from them and does
it so
i've always encouraged young artists to
at first when they're young to
take a piece say well i want to do it
like that and start to rip it off
because
that's how you will find your own voice
as they say and
or style or however you want to refer to
it and and that
that's that's good that's what it's
supposed to be that's the cultural
transfer
that happens from generation to
generation i feel very confident that i
can do production i can make the film
look good i can have beautiful
photography
if i can find even if i can't
afford big stars or actors i can find
new actors who'll be good i feel
very confident comfortable about that
where i am
least confident most insecure
is the writing because this is what i
always considered as a young person i
wanted to be a writer i have been
writing ever since i was you know maybe
19 18 years old and always felt
oh i have no talent as a writer i wish i
could have talent and
i think writing is one of those areas
acting as another
where if you're not very good at it if
you try and you work and you
try and you write and you write and you
write or you act
you can actually get better the way i
write is it's like i have a great big
bowl of dough pasta and i'm
writing and you know once in a while i
take some
and i make a pizza or i make a cake or
something
but it's all it's all the pasta of my
life
all the ideas i have something i saw
or a dream or an observation
or an and the important thing is that it
doesn't have to be a
whole developed idea it just has to be
like a seed
and then when i'm ready i will just um
work on it every day maybe in the
morning because the morning
is the time when you're very rested and
then after i have
maybe you know whatever it is 60 70
pages
then i'll read it then what i like to do
now is i like to
take it and write it as a short story
and the reason i like to write it as a
short story because
i look at it from another way in a short
story you're able to
say things that you can't say in a
screen and
very often i will just um
one thing i've learned is maybe just
write the ending
because the ending is uh obviously very
important
and it's where everything has to go and
otherwise if you don't just write the
ending that you're going to be saying oh
i don't have an ending
very often i leave it as a short story
and i even show it to my colleagues as a
short story
and then we go and we look we talk about
the actors or we go look for
locations or whatever but we only have
the short story and we find locations
and sometimes the locations are very
unusual
and you say wow we could just really use
that and you know that
notes are important and then um
when when we're starting to get closer
then it's time to write the screenplay
and so in the screenplay
i can incorporate some things about the
actors we've thought about
or the locations at any rate now is the
first time
that i translate it all into a classroom
that's more or less my process now okay
well i went to the ucla in those days
there were
two or three big film schools there was
ucla
and usc and in new york there was nyu
to make it more clear for you marty
scorsese went to nyu
george lucas went to usc and i went to
ucla
and no one from any film school had ever
made a feature movie
ever so you know i sort of
went to ucla with a big advantage
because i had been a
a theater student and a theater student
one of the you know fundamental things a
theater student has to learn
is about writing and acting well
writing and acting are the magical
ingredients of any
theater or cinema performance you could
see a movie and it could have beautiful
photography
and it can have great art direction but
if it has terrible acting
and a dumb script it's not going to be
successful yet
a film that has a wonderful script and
wonderful acting that has terrible
photography and terrible
art direction and everything else can be
a hit so
i always say that acting and writing is
the water and
is the oxygen oxygen and hydrogen that
make water
that if you if you focus on the writing
and the acting of course you want the
music and the
photography everything to be beautiful
but those are really where the magic
i think happens so having come from
theater i
knew a lot of a lot more about acting
than any of the cinema students who were
much more into the camera
the great film director orson welles
once said that you can learn
everything about how to make movies in a
weekend
meaning the camera the editing and more
or less of course that's a little
overdoing it
he when he made his first film had a
great photographer but nonetheless
it's somewhat true the camera and stuff
is not the hard part the hard part is
the writing and the acting
i i i what i feel in a nutshell to get
off apocalypse
is that we live in a world right now
that if anything
needs a cinema that sheds light on life
and on
relationships with men and women and
family and ideals and
and and but in a new form and a new
content
whereas the film industry basically is
such an
important industry that it by by nature
must keep manufacturing a product
because it has to have the people go
back every day like you do at
a fast food thing so they're into and
the whole and when i say the cinema it's
the whole
hub of it the criticism the studios
everyone
wants there just to be basically old
content
done well and i feel suddenly you know
there are all these young
people writing scripts hoping to be
discovered to make their fortune
and i just feel it sooner or later some
god knows 19 year old is going to write
a script that's really about
life and that is about that is new
because once again it's about
something real you fear that you think
that's going to happen i would assume
that there must be
50 scripts around people they're all
writing scripts that's the next
sleepless in seattle or the next film
noir or
no one writes a film about what they
think about their their their brother
but are they doing that and i mean
that's what marty started doing too i
mean he went back and wrote a film mean
streets
right was about just that the kind of
thing you're talking about that's why it
was so welcome
you've always done things in a very big
way
well number one that's an element of
movies and why they're so important that
they that they have quality and
integrity because they have such a
tremendous influence on on the world and
on people and
the fact that someone will remember a
phrase or a character will
go to someone's heart shows that this is
a really important thing and that uh
film should be made with that kind of
quality and and and
and i believe that filmmaking as
probably as everything is a game you
should play with all your cards and all
your dice and
whatever else you got and and so each
time i make a movie i give it everything
i have
and i think everyone should and i think
everyone should do everything they do
that way
for example how much did apocalypse now
cost to make
31 million dollars 31 million
have you ever had nightmares francis
that if it had been a disaster which it
certainly isn't if it had been a
disaster
what would you have done well
being realistically i mean bankruptcy no
i mean bankruptcy i'm a
large motion picture director i can go
out and get a job
and make in a year what most people
don't even dream about ever having in
their lives
so it would be a sin for me not to risk
what i had earned because i can make it
back again
and that's what to me the trust is the
reason i can make that much money
is because i'm going to really give it
my best shot and that means in the
apocalypse case that meant
putting up all the stuff you're worth so
i did it i mean to me it is not as
amazing i'm surprised that people
are surprised i was so impressed i'd
never seen
of course the silent film i'd never seen
film
that worked like that and it was on that
day that i said i
wanted to uh to be a film director and
not
a theater person and it's funny because
eisenstein himself who was a theater
uh designer uh in his in his uh
autobiography refers to the fact that on
a certain day
equally he said the cart broke and the
the driver fell into cinema
so he had a kind of and for a while
eisenstein became
a little bit of a guiding influence
because i i felt it was very good that i
get a good theater basis in
theater craft and acting uh and then go
on to movies and
to this day for young people i would
very much recommend that they work
in one act the one act play form and and
and with actors and
and in theater before they get involved
in uh in the movies and a lot of
directors don't have
really the experience with working with
actors that they might get if they
because
they go to film school and then go
directly to working in the movies and
never hit a theater so
even in film school it's amazing really
all over the country
there could be a film department and a
theater department and the students
don't mix they don't know each other
the directing students in the film
department will never go and do one-act
plays which is the best thing a film
director could do
the first work with the performances and
the content without the
burden or the the the the obligation of
the camera
you know and then having done some
one-act plays and really have a sense of
how you you help an actor get to what
you want then go on and start to see
what's the best way to
put a camera to it well i know what you
know george is what i used to call
i always call an old stick in the mud
because george is very
conservative although his imagination is
wild
but in his personal life he's pretty
conservative and i'm the opposite i'm
much more i'm not afraid of
taking chances and taking risks because
you
we so far what we know you get this one
life
and the worst thing that could possibly
happen when you're this old old old man
or old woman to say
be there getting ready to die saying oh
i wish i had done this
i wish i had done that i wish that's
that's
you don't want to do that in my case i'm
going to say oh i got to make movies and
i got to see my kids make movies and i
got to make wine and i got to do
experimental workshops
and i'm going to be so busy talking
about all the things i got to do
that when i die i'm not going to notice
it
[Laughter]
and that's my recommendation
you